[Applaudissements]
explications les séries on vous parle
toujours des clashs voilà qui se passe
dans la télévision et aujourd'hui on va
parler du direct skygate puisqu'on a des
nouvelles de gérer de stargate une vidéo
compromettante de jeremstar a été
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux par la
cab et ben voila je rappelle du grimp un
petit rappel des faits ce garçon akwaba
aurait également continuer sur twitter
en accusant un proche de jeremstar
pascal cardona surnommé baby beel
d'avoir des rapports sexuels avec des
mineures mais surtout de leur promettre
de rencontrer le chroniqueur télé pour
les attirer comme le rapporte le
parisien
et selon les dires de l'attaché de
presse de akwa babe jeremstar était
totalement au courant de ce que faisait
pascal cardona alors rien ne prouve pour
l'instant je vous dis la participation
de jeremstar assez business sexuelle
mais gérard et voilà donc il était il
était potes de ce pascal cardona et
jérôme star avait réagi à travers deux
communiqué où il nie les faits qui lui
étaient reprochés et bien le giram
stargate fait énormément parler car j'ai
un star est une personnalité médiatique
très très influent nous le savons et
depuis ses débuts c'est vrai qu'il a
bien évolué et on a des nouvelles de
jeremstar gates puisque pascal cardona
est sorti du silence et jeremstar
également jeremstar regardez c'est
qu'ils saluent les vermines aujourd'hui
je reçois dans ma baignoire une nouvelle
mot ruche des princes de l'amour
un symbole honni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cherry et aria un truc qui est très
bon c'est que y'a je voudrais en grand
nombre à ces très fort antoine griezmann
qui a twitté qui a dit que cyril hanouna
était un ouf
donc voila et sa bosse de ouf depuis sur
les réseaux sociaux donc antoine voilà
je t'embrasse et effectuerez le choc de
deux mondes
great championne du monde en toile avec
la france et je peux payer va être
meilleur buteur de la coupe du monde
j'en suis sûr alors oui mais celle ci va
être nettoyé voir une suite puisque une
enquête préliminaire a été ouverte sur
toile à l'usman et n'a rien fait la
norme est donc non alors donc hier
pascal cardona s'est exprimé dans les
colonnes de libération
il reconnaît avoir eu des relations
sexuelles avec des jeunes mais qu'il a
toujours demandé des garanties pour
savoir s'ils étaient majeurs s'ils
étaient majeurs et il n'en veut pas
gérer une star qui s'est complètement
désolidarisé lui dit aujourd'hui il
s'est désolidarisé de moi mais c'est
tout à fait normal car nous sommes
attaqués de toutes parts je ne lui en
veux pas et il ya le producteur de salut
les terriens qui s'est prononcé
aujourd'hui stéphane simon salut les
terriens et je vais vous dire où ça on
est également avec ses beats voulait
réagir là-dessus
gilles et isabelle et je vais vous
montrer ce qu a dit stéphane simon oui
enquête préliminaire ouverte donc à
nîmes
ça veut dire que il ya quatre
plaignantes qui seront entendus tout
comme jeremstar tout le monde va pouvoir
s'exprimer et ensuite on verra si ça va
plus loin
ça ne veut aucunement dire que les gens
sont coupables exactement ça ça prouve
que les autorités estiment qu'il y à la
matière pour enquêter
voilà moi et après je vais vous dire un
petit truc qui m'énerve au plus haut
point en ce moment qui se passe dans les
médias sur cette affaire jeremstar et
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
parce que je trouve ça nul
nullissime nul à chier vous allez me
dire souvent c'est juste avant j'aurais
qu'on garde la réaction de stéphane
simon donc le producteur des terriens du
dimanche émission dans laquelle et
jérôme star regarde que jeremstar
reviendra à l'antenne un jour et si oui
quand bah il va falloir que la justice
fasse son oeuvre ce qui est embêtant
c'est que ça va prendre du temps
alors qu'on voit bien qu'il est quand
même très lointainement mêlé à tout ça
enfin je me mêle pas de ce qui attend
les dans ses affaires mais j'ai
l'impression et je lui fais confiance
a priori donc il peut pas être à
l'antenne tank ya pas de rebond dans l'
enquête est temps que les policiers
n'ont pas avancé
donc est-ce qu'on va le revoir tout de
suite non la réponse est non on le veut
on le retrouvera pas ni la semaine
prochaine et la suivante dont alors
voilà donc ses fans seront donc le
producteur pour l'instant on ne va pas
revoir jeremstar j'ai encore eu le
président de la chaîne tout à l'heure
franck appietto qui me disait pour
l'instant tant qu'on n'est pas sûr
vraiment qu'il n'y a rien il ne
reviendra pas sur l'antenne de ses 8
chez remstar ayant un petit truc qui
m'énerve c'est que j'ai eu le président
aussi de ses 8 août à l'heure puisqu'il
me dit en fait toutes les chaînes et
c'est d'avoir g
une star on y interviewe mois cette
espèce de truc de corbeaux qui viennent
un voilà et qui veulent vraiment aller
chercher la merde et les vautours les
branchements et voilà les vautours qui
veulent voilà à chercher la merde voilà
et essayer d'avoir l'invité absolument
jeremstar pour faire de l'audience
franchement je trouve ça mais je trouve
ça dégueulasse voilà je vous dis
qu'avant donc il faut il ya déjà des
gens voyaient venir au tf qui le veulent
absolument y a des gens voilà cette fois
surtout les gens de tf1 je vous le dis
le groupe tf1 veut absolument qu'il
vienne chez eux et le patron de cevital
a été clair avec jeremstar s'il va faire
de la et témoigner sur une autre
émission que celle de thierry ardisson
dans laquelle ils travaillent
il sera tout de suite bien sûr sortie de
ses 8 franchement je ne trouvais pas ça
non je trouvais pas ça nulle franchement
d'autant plus que ce garçon a été
certainement bien méprisé exogènes et
maintenant tout le monde le veut
évidemment ça c'est mes côtés il le veut
une fois pour se servir pour le dégager
exactement c'est dégueulasse art et
essai là je nuancerais quand même parce
que moi pour le suivre depuis longtemps
il avait eu une pleine page dans
libération
oui navan laouer sur wii mais là il
commence à être médiatisé vous parle il
était pas eu envie d émission ils vont
le cas c'est s'il y va leur but c'est ça
bien sûr exhiber et puis il en sera
victime donc il est assez intelligent
mon avis pour savoir avec ses avocats où
est son intérêt mais effectivement du
côté de tf1 on veut le sortir dollars un
coup pour après le briser toujours été
la règle du jeu cyril vous savez très
bien que les chaînes veulent à tout pris
l'exclusivité 1 se faire mousser et 2
faire de l'audience sur la question
jeremstar doit-il vu revenir à la
télévision dans l'état actuel des choses
non ce serait très nuisible à l'image de
la chaîne ainsi l'image des producteurs
est globalement à l'image de jeremstar
temple affaire n'est pas bouclé oui la
vraie question qui se pose en fait c est
ce que jeremstar bon il ya présomption
d'innocence on le rappelle sans arrêt
j'ai payé certains l'oublient vous avoir
comme s'il a été complices de ces actes
présumés le problème il est là vie que
nos anciens questions ou disposant
questions électorales heures du mans
mais bon la chasse que vous n'avez
jamais eu d'histoire vous oui je suis
pas ce que vous en fichez totalement
d'haradheere il pas j'ai suivi comme
tout le monde
après pour moi pour revenir à l'antenne
ou pas il y vit on n'est jamais mort en
télé je pense même comme la politique on
n'est jamais mort il mettra du temps me
reviendra par contre ces émissions
moi je vois déjà les vannes arriver oui
au thibault moi je veux dire c'est comme
un peu si on parle de jeremstar tant
parler de jean luc lahaye avec tout ce
qu il a été soupçonné de plein de choses
il est toujours à la télé au cinéma
donc pourquoi pas pour l'instant donné
il a été condamné les comptes à vue puis
sur les autres puisqu'elle a été relaxé
jean luc lahaye ce que vous suivez tout
ça c'était pas douter vous sur vos
tournois tous à la télé et non pas du
tout et comme tu dis là d'art cas là
c'est un truc de fou parce que moi c'est
la première fois que je vois le visage
de jeune homme s'est avancé vers ben non
moi tu savais même pas que c'était à nom
est bon avec ma fille me dit tout le
temps qu'ils aient 20 codes jeremstar
pour un über moins cher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]